- [Interviewer] All right.
Amber.
- Hey.
- [Interviewer] Welcome back again.
- Hi.
- [Interviewer] So, what's the latest?
You got a rough-
- [Amber] A rough couple of months, right?
- [Interviewer] Yes, exactly.
- Okay, so, the worst is that
I tested positive for COVID.
And I was sick.
And I found out while I was sick
that there's not many resources
for homeless people.
So I was stuck.
But the best part is,
today I go into rehab.
- [Interviewer] You
decided to go to rehab?
- I have to go to rehab.
My life has become
completely unmanageable.
(laughing)
I give up.
I tap out.
- [Interviewer] That's
probably a great thing, right?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Your life just seemed
to be spiraling downward
ever since our first-
- I'm burnt out, as the
phrase would go, you know,
I'm burnt out.
If you look at the before-
almost as bad as some of
the other people I know.
It's weird.
But, yeah, I'm burnt out.
I can't do it no more.
I can't.
Between my life and-
the street life and my life,
I'm destroyed.
I destructed.
- [Interviewer] So you're leaving today?
- Today, yes.
Like 90 days.
- [Interviewer] 90 days?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Have
you done rehab before?
- This will be my fourth rehab.
I've tried since 2015.
So, they keep saying
just keep coming back.
And I keep going back.
This has gotta be different
this time, though.
- [Interviewer] Is the core
of the problem with addiction,
is it really the drug
or is it the trauma you through
as a kid and all the shame
from all the bad decision that-
- It's the trauma.
- [Interviewer] I mean, your
kids cause a lot of shame
and pain for you, I'm sure,
and that's hard to deal with.
So the drugs numb that.
And then you--
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's
like a downward spiral.
- Yeah.
It's the childhood trauma
and then adult trauma
and then having children.
And I'm afraid to traumatize them.
Yes.
For me, my problem is my life.
Or my issues in my life.
The drugs are just what
I use to get through it
or cope, I guess, I don't know.
But, I gotta go back.
I have to.
I want my life back.
Some part of it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
it'd be nice to see you
do some of the things you talked about
in that first interview.
- Right.
At least one thing, you know.
Something.
I feel like a failure,
but I'm gonna be okay.
I'll be okay.
I just basically came
down here, Mark, today
because I want to thank you the most
because you've been really there for me.
Here for me.
And I don't think I would've
gotten this far without you.
So I wanted to tell you thank you
and also, I want you to
see me before I went.
When I come back, I'm
gonna be fantabulous.
So, that's where my mind's at.
- [Interviewer] You've been
through a lot this year,
and I would love to see-
and you're an intelligent,
beautiful woman,
I would love to see you, kind
of, get your life together.
It would be so great to see that.
But, there's only so much I can do.
I can put you in a motel room for a week.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] I can help you
with this, that and the other
but that's not really gonna fix anything.
- Right.
Now it's my turn to do my part.
Because you and the other
people have stepped in for me.
So now it's time for me to
put my words into actions.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I think courage is the piece of the puzzle
that a lot of people can't come up with.
- Love and courage.
- [Interviewer] Love and courage, yeah.
Forgiveness.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] There's
a lot of things, but-
- I just wanna make a change.
See what happens.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I think it's coming
to that final thoughts,
fix it or die.
I'm not ready to die yet.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Because you'll end up dead
living that life, right?
- Yeah, living the life and the lifestyle
with all the drama-
- [Interviewer] Of people that
are living that lifestyle,
working Figaro or similar
tracks around the city
or around the country,
how many of them do you
think are addicted to drugs?
- [Amber] I don't know,
probably about 40 percent.
I'm not really sure.
In my area, it's high, say 75 percent.
In my area.
But I'm sure there's other tracks
where there's, like, girls
out there getting their money,
you can still get a cigarette, you know.
So I don't really know.
I haven't been in any
other state to state areas
or anything like that.
Just down in that Figaro area.
So I haven't really had
a chance to experience
what it's actually like to
work in(indistinct), you know.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I think the drugs
are pretty common.
There's a few here and
there that don't use
but a lot of the ones that
even tell you they don't,
are not being honest.
- [Amber] Right.
- [Interviewer] But there are some.
- [Amber] I'm sure, I'm sure.
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in all of this?
Especially this year, 'cause
you've been through so much.
- [Amber] Lesson?
Don't get high no matter what.
That's the biggest lesson I learned.
No matter what.
Because I did and all
these things happened to me
and getting high didn't make it better.
- [Interviewer] Getting high
is never the answer, is it?
- [Amber] Right.
I think I would rather have
dealt with that stuff sober.
Because, maybe, I would've
had a better outcome
and it would never have
gotten as far as it got.
Or went.
- [Interviewer] And the
rehab you're going to,
is there therapy involved in that?
- No, no, not therapy
but you are allowed to
seek outside therapy.
I'm an alumni of this certain program
that I'm going back to
and when I was there,
I knew something was wrong with my mental
so I did it on my own.
And they allow you to go
and inquire on your own
about your own mental health,
but it's not part of the diagnosis.
- [Interviewer] I would think therapy
would be a big part of recovery.
- Yeah, it has to be.
In my program, therapy
is called a meeting.
You obviously get a sponsor
and you get all onto that.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
anything you'd like to do
if you got clean and
got your life together?
- Yeah, I'd like to make, not amends,
but I have, like, a couple of people
that I hurt out here, you know.
My best friend.
There's like maybe three people
that I just wanna say,
"Girl, I'm not high no more
so let me apologize to you
while I'm in the right
frame of mind," you know.
I just wanna do that kind of situation.
And I'll make amends,
like, what fellowship says
but if I can do this,
It'll help me feel better
and I won't be holding on to that.
A slight bit of garbage
that's affected me in my life
and I lost a real important person.
- [Interviewer] The
drugs make you do things
that you normally would never do.
- They're going to make you do things
that you would normally never do.
Destroy, deplorable, horrible.
They're going to.
It's just a matter of when.
Maybe not in the beginning, but one day
you're gonna do some shit, excuse me,
some things and you're gonna think,
"Damn. I don't believe I just did that.
That goes against
anything I was ever taught
or believed or common
sense and everything.
But that end result
(Amber exhales)
It serves it's purpose.
But, yeah, definitely gonna do things
you just never thought that you'd do.
I don't care who you are
or what you tell yourself.
Even if it's taking 10
cents away from your son.
That's still something you
thought you would never do
as minor and as slight as it is.
Don't think that you would never
do that to your son sober, right.
It was only 10 cents.
It something you would never have thought
that you were going to do.
- [Interviewer] All right, darlin',
well I wish you the best of luck.
- [Amber] See you soon.
- [Interviewer] All
right, darlin', thank you.
- [Amber] All right, thank you.
Yeah, I'll be better when I come back.
I'll be able to speak...